And now for the answer. This is something that we can best find out by testing.
Here's our first input, here comes the second, number 3 with the quotes outside,
and number 4 with the quotes inside of the text.
For the first input, the output should be just the text foo.
For the second one, it should be the same but enclosed in double quotes
as is the same for the third one.
For the fourth one, we'd simply expect the text foo. Let's go and test this.
Surprise, surprise. The output is very different from what we expected.
To start with, the third output still has HTML markup,
but for the second input has also something fishy going on because the quotes
that were actually part of the text have been removed.
In our quiz, we only cared for the HTML markup,
so the third input definitely produces HTML markup.
And therefore, this is the correct answer.